用声音 碰撞世界 生动活泼。
生动早咖啡 与你轻松同步日常生活与商业世界。
嗨各位早上好呀 今天是2026年的6月24号星期三。
这里是生动早咖啡 我是来自生动活泼的梦一。
字节将要发布的新版AI视频生成模型 会有怎样的新功能。
未预据头头头 为什么能够在半导体领域分一杯羹。
今天节目的上半部分 就会和你一起来了解这些问题。
在今天节目的后半段 想和你一起来聊聊一家日本的。
连锁二手服装公司 叫做Second Street。
通常来说 人们印象中线下的二手服装店。
往往都会是一家家独立的门店 或者是小规模的连锁。
店内的衣服 陈烈 也总是能够体现店主自己的品味。
但今天我们说的这家二手服装店。
却是一个门店数量接近上千家的公司。
它的主营模式 就是从消费者的手里 买进旧的衣服。
经过一些处理之后 再摆上货架卖出去。
在二手行业里 能够做大规模的品类。
通常都是黄金 万表 设置品包袋。
还有数码产品 这些容易标准发定价的东西。
而服装因为有太多的品牌款式和尺码。
这些都在放大 它在二手产业里规模化经营的难度。
但是今天要聊的Second Street这家公司。
他们在日本的门店数量。
甚至已经比日本的优衣库门店数量还要多。
那这家公司到底是怎么把二手服装。
做成规模化的连锁生意的。
今天我们的清洁读就与此相关。
在这之前 我们下来关注几条简短的商业科技动态。
字节跳动将发布C Dance 2.5。
6月23号的上午。
字节跳动旗下的云服务生火山引擎宣布。
将会在7月初正式发布新版AI视频生成模型C Dance 2.5。
目前C Dance 2.5已经处于内侧尾声。
根据财新的报道
C Dance 2.5的核心能力是以3D界模型式做预言。
由模型生成画面主体的早期界模。
可以在模拟镜头运动。
实现预期中的运镜一致性灯的效果之后。
再渲染对应的材质、光影。
生成成熟的镜头
这也意味着C Dance 2.5。
能够进一步的提升模型。
在商用和专业影视创作领域的实用性。
财新认为在AI视频领域。
全行业会大面积地接入。
取得突破性进展的新模型。
抛弃旧的模型
今年2月发布的C Dance 2.0。
改变了中国短距行业。
市场上大部分的短距开始直接由AI生成。
AI视频需求也推动了字节云服务商。
火山引擎的收入激增。
不过有内侧四格的用户透露。
使用C Dance 2.5的4K。
输出30秒视频
成本超过200元。
这和当前追求低成本。
快速出品的短距行业。
有着明显的区别
茶百道推出首个咖啡联名产品。
根据财经网6月22号的报道。
茶百道在最近和国曼IP凡人动画合作。
推出了他们的第一个咖啡联名产品。
有家门商表示
他们把门店营业时间提早到了七点半。
咖啡业务能够给门店的早餐时段订单量。
带来提升
目前茶百道已经上信了十多款咖啡产品。
咖啡业务覆盖的门店数量。
也从年初的大约200家。
增长到了超过2700家。
界民新闻的分析认为过去一年。
包括股民秘血冰城在内的新茶营品牌。
正在集体下场做咖啡。
这些品牌本来就擅长快速上心和供应链整合。
同时还拥有庞大的门店网络。
和吸引年轻用户的经验。
当茶营市场逐渐触碰天花板。
争夺咖啡市场就成为了必然的选择。
Google和电影工作室AE24在AI方面展开合作。
6月22号Google DeepMind与电影工作室AE24达成合作。
华尔街日报的报道显示。
DeepMind将会投资7500万美元。
两家公司会共同开发用于电影制作的AI工具。
Google DeepMind还将会获得领先艺术家的反馈和指导。
但是协议并不允许Google访问AE24的影视作品库等等数据。
这是Google DeepMind第一次与成熟的电影制片厂建立合作关系。
好莱坞行业媒体认为。
Google是为数不多拥有AI视频生成工具的科技巨头之一。
这次的合作很可能会进一步的加深他们的布局。
目前AE24内部也有一支团队正在开发AI生成分禁的相关应用。
行业媒体指出
分禁正在成为影视行业热门的AI应用场景。
它能够确保最终面向观众的作品仍然是由人类主导的。
几周之前著名的导演马丁斯科赛斯也宣布了类似的计划。
位域巨头加码半导体业务。
根据《日经》新闻6月22号的报道。
日本浴室设备制造商Toto。
计划在未来5年内投资大约4.95亿美元。
扩展他们的半导体材料业务。
希望为下一代一纳米制成的芯片制造提供支持。
而目前最先进的量产芯片制成还是台积电的两纳米。
Toto将陶瓷位域的烧制技术用于半导体材料的制作。
他们的主要产品之一就是静电吸盘。
用来在芯片制造过程当中固定归金元。
对材料的抗污耐腐蚀。
以及耐高温性能的要求极高。
Toto的产品由于采用的是高纯度陶瓷。
也受到了客户的侵赖。
《日经》新闻指出Toto在上世纪80年代。
就进入了半导体材料业务。
但是长期亏损
直到2020年之后。
AI半导体的需求飙升。
情况才发生了改变。
目前Toto包括半导体材料在内的新业务部门。
只占到了公司整体营收的10%。
但是他们贡献的利润。
却已经占到了总利润的一半以上。
超过了Toto核心的未预业务。
以上就是我们为你梳理的几条商业科技动态。
下面和我一同走进到今天的清解读时间。
欢迎来到今天的清解读。
根据彭博的报道截止到今年3月。
日本二手服装企业Second Street。
在日本开出了900多家门店。
而U1库在日本的门店数量还不到800家。
在日本的二手行业除了Second Street。
门店数量超过1000家的公司。
经营的大多都是金士。
包袋还有数码产品这些。
能够标准化定价的品类。
而这些门店有很大一部分。
都是通过加盟的方式开设的。
在欧美地区也有一些大型的。
连走二手服装门店。
比如在北美有3000多家门店的Goodwill。
但他们实际上是一家非营利组织。
货源都来自于免费捐赠。
经营的收益也都要投入到工艺事业。
像Second Street的这种。
以职营的模式
把二手服装开到接近千家的门店。
放眼全球都很少见。
Second Street在日本的900多家门店。
已经覆盖了日本全部的47个都道府线。
再加上他们在美国、中国、台湾。
还有东南亚等地方的海外门店。
他们全球门店数量已经超过了1000家。
他们的母公司也在日本二手行业的收入。
排到了第一
比第二名要高出7成。
那这家二手服装连锁。
到底是怎么开出上千家门店规模的呢？
原因之一
日本闲置经济的传统。
其实在2022年的一期节目当中。
我们就介绍过日本由来已久的二手经济。
二战之后日本经济高速增长。
当时大量的消费导致日本居民。
拥有了充足的闲置物品。
不过日本经济随后经历下滑。
也让居民开始出售手头的旧货。
去年日本一家智库的测算显示。
日本家庭闲置超过一年的物品。
总价值在91万亿日元左右。
约合5700亿美元。
其中时尚服装类的物品占比最大。
超过了三分之一
同时伴随着消费能力的下降。
也让消费者的观念更加务实。
于是也有越来越多的人选择购买二手商品。
彭博的分析认为
从2022年开始。
长期处于通货紧缩的日本社会。
也开始经历一轮显著的通胀周期。
物价的上涨要比工资的涨幅更高。
而日元汇率的下跌。
也导致欧洲时尚品牌在日本的价格越来越高。
而从二手店买衣服。
也从一个小众爱好。
变成了很多人的生活日常。
另外由于日本二手商品的品相。
普遍相对较好
所以日本的二手店也成为了海外时尚爱好者。
专门跑来逃货的地方。
日本环境省公布的数据显示。
从2009年到2024年。
日本的二手市场一直处于增长的状态。
而且整体的市场规模。
在15年的时间里增长了两倍多。
原因之二
Second Street的母公司。
所带来的全国门店网络。
Second Street在1996年成立。
最初他们只是一个区域性的联索公司。
2008年
他们被一家叫做GEO的公司收购。
GEO之前的主营业务和早期的耐飞比较相似。
他们也是做录像带的租赁生意。
后来通过并购扩张。
GEO成为了日本录像带租赁行业的。
主要企业之一
此外他们还涉及二手游戏卡带的业务。
当时日本的著作权法要求。
影视录像带和游戏卡带的租赁。
都需要获得影视公司和游戏公司的允许。
而影视行业和租赁行业。
确定了一套利润分享机制。
租赁影视录像带并不会影响出品方的收益。
但是游戏公司却更希望。
消费者能够购买新的卡带。
所以他们也通常不太愿意。
开放游戏租赁的授权。
这就导致GEO拓展游戏业务的时候。
无法直接租赁游戏卡带。
而是建立了一套
收购游戏再出售的二手机制。
GEO在2000年前后判断。
他们主营的影视录像带租赁业务。
未来很可能会走下坡路。
所以他们也选择了此前。
通过游戏卡带涉及过的二手业务。
当时不同的竞争对手。
实际上已经进入了像。
书籍、数码产品
还有设置品等等不同的二手交易领域。
而且已经建成了全国性的连锁体系。
但是服饰是二手市场里。
体量最大
购买屏次最高的品类。
而且当时还没有全国性的相关企业。
所以GEO决定收购。
主打二手服装生意的Second Street。
尽管他们认为
衣服的鉴定非常依赖人的经验。
而且也无法像书籍。
或者是游戏那样标准化。
但是正是因为有这些门槛。
二手服装的竞争也会小很多。
GEO本身就在日本全国。
运营大量的影视租赁门店。
这些不同地区的选址经验。
也可以直接用于Second Street的经营。
日本的一家投行认为。
二手服装最大的问题在于货源。
他们无法像衣手的服装门店。
一样自己生产
或者是批量采购衣服。
而是需要销售自己收购来的衣服。
因此Second Street格外重视。
服装的收购环节
WIS他们也设计了不同的门店类型。
在核心城区
他们开设专门收购衣服的门店。
直买不卖
面积也不需要很大。
专门覆盖那些不开车的都市人群。
而在郊区他们就会。
开设配备停车场的大型门店。
有Second Street的前员工。
在接受采访的时候表示。
如果单看价格
线上平台的回收价格。
几乎总是会比Second Street的更高。
但是卖家需要拍照上架游记。
等买家确认收获之后才能够拿到钱。
而前往Second Street的顾客。
只需要把衣服拿到门店。
等待鉴定之后就可以直接拿到现金。
现如今影视租赁
只占到了Second Street母公司。
GEO不到一成的收入。
二手业务已经成为了他们的。
主要收入来源
所以GEO计划在今年。
直接把名字改成Second Retailing。
原因之三
通过人力体系
解决二手服装行业的难题。
Second Street的表示。
他们覆盖七千多个品牌。
每个品牌下面又有不同的款式。
甚至同一个款式
不同年份的服装都会有所区别。
所以他们也采用了。
人力定价的收购方式。
Second Street在全日本的直营门店。
配备了大约一万名买手。
他们在门店里
主要负责查验顾客所带来的衣服。
给出定价
而且Second Street还给买手。
设置了四个不同的等级。
还会对买手进行定期的考试。
这些考试的内容覆盖。
市场价格、品牌知识、流行单品等等。
不同等级买手的考核难度。
也会逐级递进
这家公司还会在内部。
举办一个名字叫做。
买手之王Kin of Bayer的竞赛。
同时他们还会定期的。
举办学习会
让公司的讲师
给不同门店的买手进行培训。
比如在定价的时候。
买手需要参考二手衣服的。
品牌、款式、年份还有状态。
甚至还需要考虑
流行趋势和季节变化。
比如一件羽绒服
秋天的收购价
就会比春天更高
不过主要依赖人力的模式。
也会让衣服的回收价格。
存在一定的浮动
有人把26件衣服。
拿到三家不同的Second Street门店。
进行鉴定
结果三家门店
给出的总价都不太一样。
其中最多的估价差了8000多日元。
约合300多人民币。
另外Second Street的经营模式。
现在也在面临一系列的挑战。
比如对人力相对较高的投入。
以及执营的模式扩张。
都会让这家公司的利润率比较低。
有研究机构进行了策算。
Second Stream公司。
Geo的利润率
要低于日本其他的二手企业。
即使他们在日本的门店数量。
超过了优一库
他们的利润还不到优一库的十分之一。
另外日本二手服装行业的竞争压力。
也在增加
像是日本最大的商社之一。
一腾中商市入股了二手平台。
Bookoff
还计划把旗下的全家便利店。
当做二手商品的接收点。
而服装品类
也是Bookoff增长最快的品类之一。
那你平时都会怎么处理。
换季清出来的旧衣服。
你又会在什么样的渠道。
来出售自己闲置的东西呢？
欢迎在我们的评论区。
和我们一块来聊聊。
当然今天节目的最后。
也想和你来聊聊奖杯这个话题。
你也许听说过世界杯的奖杯。
名字叫做大力神杯。
不过你知道吗？
大力神杯是中国媒体给它起的外号。
它其实是世界杯的第二代奖杯。
而第一代奖杯
雷米特杯声势坎坷。
从它第一次出场到最终的消失。
几乎可以拍一部连续剧。
而这背后
也是世界杯本身的历史变迁。
那么雷米特杯为什么会换成了。
大力神杯
雷米特杯的名字又是怎么来的。
你可以点开单级简介链接。
到Noknok世界节目里。
收听这个奖杯的历险剂。
好啦这就是今天的生动早咖啡。
那我们明天一早再见啦。
拜拜